it's been a while since we last visited
Egypt and covered any of its mythology
so today we take a look at a goddess I
have previously mentioned in my video on
best stet a goddess that is commonly
associated of war destruction and
retribution but on the other hand was
also seen as a goddess of healing
medicine and the Sun if you haven't
already guessed I am indeed a frantisek
met the lioness and warrior goddess of
Egyptian myth
the very name Sekhmet was believed to
have derived from the Egyptian word set
him men in power to be strong and to be
mighty unlike many of the fiercest
goddesses that appear in the Egyptian
pantheon she was part of a collection
known as the I of raw
this included Hathor Bastet y jet mutt
and of course Sekhmet herself now I have
previously discussed her Sekhmet
ambassador to often consider to be the
same deity with them both having the
head of a lioness being the daughter of
rah and marrying the god of
craftsmanship in architecture pitar it
was fairly common for the god of
fragrance and beauty Netherton to be
attributed as either the son of Bastet
or Sekhmet despite the numerous
similarities between the two goddesses
there were still several ways that one
could distinguish between them statues
of Bastet would often be green whereas
those of Sekhmet would be red and she
would often be seen where in a solar
disk to represent her association of the
Sun now in time bastard's appearance
would change to more of a domestic house
cat and she would be known for the
protection of family and the Home
Secretary taint her fierce lioness
appearance and she was seen as far more
unpredictable and destructive than
Bastet now as time continued to pass the
connection between the two began to fade
and instead best as in Sekhmet was seen
as examples of Egyptian duality the
region known as Upper Egypt became
associated of segments the worship of
Bastet would not take place in the lower
portion of the Egyptian kingdom these
two regions were separated by the River
Nile and the two goddesses were now
connected by geographical location
rather mythological stories there are
quite a few variations of how sick Ahmet
came to exist
some believe that Hathor sent to Earth
by rah however when she arrived she
became sick met when she saw the humans
had been ignoring the principles of my
heart
Sekhmet on her father's behalf would
then take vengeance upon man in her rage
filled trance she became so violent that
she slaughtered humans endlessly
drinking the blood of all of those
slain WinRAR eventually saw what had
become of Sekhmet
he became so afraid of what she could do
that he filled the River Nile with beer
so it resembled blood mistake in the
beer Field Nile for blood
Sekhmet became so intoxicated that she
could no longer continue her killing
spree and fell into a deep slumber
eventually returning to her father
peacefully
the ancient Egyptians then held
festivals to pacify Sekhmet and to
celebrate the end of the battle these
are new festivals were held at the very
beginning of the year and the ancient
Egyptians would drink great deals of
wine until they became extremely drunk
they would also dance and play music to
soothe the wildness that Sekhmet
represented over the years Sekhmet
became associated of several things she
was seen as a goddess of healing but
then again she was also known as lady
pestilence bringing disease and plague
to all those who wronged her the priests
of Sekhmet was seen as extremely skilled
doctors and this somewhat resulted in
varying depictions the Lady of life but
also the Lady of terror
she was also mentioned in several of the
spells that featuring the Book of the
Dead in terms of both creation and
destruction during the period of the New
Kingdom
Sekhmet was also considered to be the
mother of mehar's the lion headed prince
and the God of War whose name meant he
who was true beside her but much like
Nephilim he was also sometimes seen as a
son of Bastet Sekhmet is one of the
fiercest warriors that we see in
Egyptian mythology but she was also seen
as a great healer two traits that aren't
often coupled together I hope you guys
and girls enjoyed some more Egyptian
mythology it's not something we've
covered for a while so feel free to
share any thoughts and ideas regarding
SiC met with me in the comments below as
always I've been your host mythology and
fiction explained
you